hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde Sand und ich habe keine Video
Idee und spielen deswegen endlich mal
wieder wer bin ich
up in the comments
hat das immer Mund und dann mache ich
aber gezogen
[Musik]
spinnst du ich glaube du spinnst er hat
eine riesen Nase ist halt so ein
bisschen aus hey halt mal deine Fresse
so
das sieht gar nichts wegen deinen Haaren
ja kann man so einmal sehen
nein es ist wieder dran
du bist doof
ah junge
okay wir sind
to go bin ich männlich ja ähm kenne ich
die Person meinst du also du kennst die
Person ja aber nicht persönlich oder was
meinst du kennst die Person persönlich
nein
nein okay bin ich männlich ja
bin ich bekannt
ja bin ich über Deutschland hinaus nein
okay würde ich die Person gerne treffen
ja habe ich den Namen von der Person
schon erwähnt irgendwann ja safe ja bin
[Gelächter]
ich
okay dann bin ich Barack Obama
bin ich Deutscher
ja ich glaube
halb halb halb halb ja also nicht
komplett deutsch glaube ich okay
klar
ich kann auf Deutsch sprechen ja okay
und ich bin aber auch eher nur im
deutschsprachigen Raum bekannt meinst du
ne ja vielleicht weiß ich gar nicht mein
Schlüssel international auch vielleicht
ein bisschen
lebe ich in Deutschland
ich würde sagen nein okay dann
ich bin dran
bin ich
Künstler also verdiene ich mein Geld mit
so künstlerischen Sachen wie
beispielsweise
filmmusikschauspiel
influencer ja
bin ich Influenza nicht direkt
keine Ahnung bisschen ähm also wenn man
die ganze Zeit ja vielleicht Influenza
okay also alle die ja Instagram Account
haben sind ja Influenza okay okay so ist
Influenza sein mein Hauptberuf
[Musik]
ja würde ich dann schon tippen ja ja
Barack Obama bin ich blond
[Musik]
ja vielleicht
ich weiß
nur eine Frage ich muss wissen
[Musik]
okay ich lebe nicht in Deutschland ich
kenne die Person nicht persönlich aber
ich würde die Person gerne treffen äh
lebe ich äh im Dach Gebet Deutschland
Österreich
[Musik]
bin ich
älter als 30
ja okay bin ich unter 50 ja okay bin ich
jünger als 40 ja okay bin ich älter als
ich glaube ja bin ich jünger als 39 bin
ich älter als 32
nee nein
nein 32 okay wenn ich nachher gut
okay noch mal Focus Sandra
er ist die Person
im Internet bekannt ja ist die Person
ist die so künstlerischen Influenza
okay krass unter anderem auch Musiker
nein
ich dachte Mark Forster nein nein nein
mag ich Fisch
ich glaube tatsächlich ja ja okay da wo
der wohnt würde ich sagen ja das heißt
er lebt am Meer weiß ich nicht
Ja oder Nein lebt der am Meer
kann sein ja ich glaube ja ich weiß
nicht aber ich denke eher so ja krass
okay
ist die Person Politiker
nein ich werde niemals aufkommen meinst
du schwer ne nein das ist eigentlich der
einfachste Begriff ja
krass bin ich neben beruflich noch in
der Schauspielkunst unterwegs nee okay
bin ich
im Fernsehen bekannt ja okay krass
eigentlich
und männlich ja aber ich bin nicht so
Influenza nee Influenza nicht nee und
auch kein Schauspieler
hast du nicht gefragt bin ich ein
Schauspieler nein oh Mann also ich bin
32 Jahre alt männlich
deutschsprachig und irgendwie Influenza
aber vielleicht auch nicht komme ich aus
der Ecke Politik gar nicht
falls denn dann hat die Person hat die
Person schon rausgebracht
nicht direkt aber ich glaube es gibt
Lieder über diese Person
aber diese Person hat noch kein Lied
rausgemacht also die Antwort ist nein
habe ich über eine Million Follower
auf Instagram
kann das sein
da bin ich
glaube jeder ist ab und zu mal irgendwie
mit ihm aber ist schon mal ein meme von
mir richtig viral gegangen dass ich das
schon mal gesehen habe ja glaube ich
schon also von hier sind Mims auf jeden
Fall schon wieder reingegangen ich kann
es natürlich nicht sagen ob die Person
das mitbekommen hat oder gesehen hat
okay bin ich Sportler nein
voll schwer also wenn du über eine
Million follow auf Instagram hast bist
du ja ein okay wir haben schon gesagt
ich bin ja Influenza quasi ne
32 kann jetzt nicht mit dem Alter ich
weiß nicht ob du darauf kommst schwer wo
bin ich Moment
[Applaus]
ich dachte gerade
34 der ist doch 88 geboren
Monte
Montana black einfach gewonnen Digger ja
darf ich meins jetzt
auch okay
Mann wie schwer
bin ich in der bin ich in der was dicker
deutsche Sprache schwere Sprache bin ich
in der EU lebe ich in der EU
das ist so dumm nein okay wenn ich in
Deinem Wohnort verrate weißt du das
direkt lebe ich in Amerika nein krass
bin ich der Weihnachtsmann
Nikolaus ja scam
ehrlich
keine Ahnung ja schön ja schön
wenn euch hier äh wer bin ich mit seiner
Luca gefallen hat dann lass gerne einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weiter Videos nichts
verpassen schreibt mir gerne unten in
die Kommentare was ihr euch zu
Weihnachten wünscht es interessiert mich
eigentlich
eure Geschenke
dann könnte natürlich die Adresse
viel Spaß
verrückt aber
keine Ahnung